um i guess i'll start off with a quick
introduction
thank you
yep
all right so
yeah thanks a lot everyone for coming
back to the last session of the workshop
and kind of to start us off we're really
happy to have uh lena lee from harvard
who's gonna tell us about learning
localized policies for multi-agent
systems so i guess i'll go ahead and let
you uh take it away lina
great thank you thank you for the
introduction and thank you for
organizing the workshop
it's a great pleasure to share some of
our recent work on io for multiagent
systems so i've been learning a lot from
the talks in the past few days and they
cover so many different experts of
multi-agent io so my talk will have some
overlap with other talks but hope the
talk can add some new perspectives
especially through the angle of cyber
physical systems
so since i only stand up for
seven-minute talk i will only give very
quick motivation on the big picture so
my research background was on the
control authorization for societal
network systems so what's really
happening in the past decades for these
systems is that our society has been
installing more and more smart connect
devices which are capable of sensing
communication and computation so with
this data generated by the devices and
with our advances in learning and we
start visualizing smart systems such as
smart houses smart transportation smart
manufacturing smart power grids and
personally i've been working on smart
grid for more than a decade
but always there's a kind of one
question when we try to
putting ourselves into a nice picture is
more iot or smart devices really mean
that we can bring
this ai success to the societal systems
to make them smother
so then we once we look into the news
looking to the reality it doesn't take
us long to realize that we are only at
the beginning stage of transforming the
societal systems to the future ones so
for the power grades every time when we
face extremely weather conditions such
as the winter storm or the heatwave the
solution that the power systems turns to
are always performing rolling blackout
affecting many people's daily life
and then for the transportation so
firstly it remains challenging to ensure
safety under complex situations for
autonomous driving but secondly even if
we solve the safety issue for autonomous
driving it is unclear how to put these
technologies together to reduce the
traffic jams and improving our mobility
so what's the reason for the state of
art of these smart systems so one of the
major reason reason is that learning for
the physical societal dynamical system
is very challenging
so now let's take a deeper look at the
future smart systems from a control
perspective so what's happening right
now is that we have more and more
sensors that spread out in the systems
the sensors can monitor the local
situations in real time and pass the
data to either the age devices or the
data centers so the data is shared among
devices and processed by advanced
algorithms
decisions will be made and password
adjectives
but so like this picture fits into the
standard control feedback loop nicely
but the key differences are the
following so first of all the sensors
and agitators are in a huge number and
they are spread out located at different
locations generating a huge amount of
data
at all the different locations so on the
one hand we have faster
computation and communication tools but
on the other hand all these technologies
are still limited
compared with the skill of the system
and moreover so once we really going to
connect all the active devices they keep
generating random vibrations into the
system making the system become one and
more complex and harder and harder to
model
all these challenges motivated people
are going to look at how about the data
and decision making tools
so like recently the data g1 tools are
people can call the reference learning
data driven like learning based control
has motivated a lot of interdisciplinary
collaborations and in particular
reinforcing learning has brought control
and learning communities together so we
have seen many remarkable successes
about rio in areas such as go video
games and robotics
however when we look into the
technologies behind the exciting news we
see major challenges in using this
method for the real world large-scale
societal system that i have been showing
before so first of all all the messages
require a huge amount of computation and
simulation behind the result
and it's hard to scale up to the large
system in real time secondly it is often
challenging to provide the radical
guarantees on high performance such as
stability robustness safety and other
conditions that we really care about for
the physical systems
so with this kind of motivation like we
try to
when we start working on this problem
we're trying to think can we even
develop some scalable method for those
multi-agents societal networks
and still have some approval guarantees
so i'm going to show like some story
that we like some success stories that
we have but the key is this it's not
really just going to changing the online
dynamical system as a just a black box
it's still going to use some knowledges
we have the systems and trying to
develop the method
so after that i will actually spend a
few minutes to come back to discuss the
solutions that we have is what exactly
the problems that we really learned so
let me dive into the first part if i
have questions feel free to stop me
anytime
now let's dive into the model so as i
mentioned the motivation for this work
is motivated by societal network systems
so we go hard to model those elements in
abstract way but still capturing some
essential
component
so in this model like first we have the
time like discount the row think about
the online control like online situation
so we have the real time stage here
and we have the state like for each
individual agent so one difference is i
think compared with other stocks we have
been listening to other multi-agent
talks is here so here i introduce the
state for individual nodes individual
agent so for the power system you can
think about each agent the nodes as kind
of one bus in the system and for the
transportation you can think about as
each road can see
condition or some other condition i have
some current example later so now i have
the individual state for individual
agent
so for individual agents they can taking
actions that's kind of making sure i
have a sensors that have adjectives so
these educators can take in local
actions so for the technical part we for
this talk i will focus on the finance
set finite state final action like the
tabular case
so there's a state transition so what
defines the network so the network in
here let me go through it is means for
each
agent his future state will depending on
his pure state and also his neighboring
state and his own actions
so
once you look at this local state
transition rule what it says it's
actually defined in some network right
wasn't that what the link here means is
if one asian state can affect another
agent's state that means they are
connected so here the link of the
network means they can affect the state
transition for the other agents so if
question feel free to ask me for this
one and for here we as i put in those
examples as that like the system just
getting more and more complex it's very
hard to really have a model to remodel
how the state transition really affects
each other so we're assuming the say
transition exactly what the pi we do not
know but one assumption we're going to
assume is oh oh because i kind of know
how the network is connected so i know
the connectivity of the network it just
i don't know specifically what's the pi
for individual link
and then we have a stage reward and for
the reward again we kind of save it for
each agent he can observe what's going
on locally and he has his local
evaluation of how good situation is this
kind of local reward for the ri
and the control policy i will come back
to talk about what control policy we
want to learn so not just at a high
level right the control policy is just
taking based on the state taking action
and a and the pi here kind of like joint
action come back to what kind of policy
we really want to have so the objective
here is i want to find a policy that's
going to
maximize the long-term reward and the
long-term reward is a summation of
everyone's reward over the different
time and i have the discounting reward
case here so i want to say the result
have been extended to the infant-type
horizon case but i will focus on the
discounting reward case to give the
intuition idea
now let me recap the
like essential part i want to highlight
is a local interaction so i have the
start with the local interaction and i
would like developing some learning rule
to learn some kind of policies to
maximize the long-term reward and i was
just thinking about like this is
different from the other talks which
talking about the games here i start
with the cooperative setting like i just
like every agent it's kind of like the
same saturated it's an engineering
component i can
rewrite i can engineering them ask them
to follow certain kind of learning rules
and i would like to making sure
eventually i can solve the system like
achieve some global good performance so
this kind of essential component here
feel free to stop me if you have
questions
so now let me give you an example right
where those kind of things come from so
first if you think about epidemic so we
have been like in the pandemic for last
past two weeks more than um two years
so like the probability of one agent
getting infected well depending on the
neighbors right who are the friends we
interact with and definitely one setting
my model didn't capture is the right now
i assuming the network structure is kind
of fixed so in this scenario the network
structure can be time-wiring and like
the weight will be also changing and
that's like one of the future work we're
probably trying to attend
extent and another one as i mentioned
the transportation for transportation
transportation system what you can think
is think about the state is the
congestion of a load so and then for the
congestion for road it is well depends
on the conjunction of the nearby dose
and that's where the local induction
comes from and you guys you can think
about some many other examples you will
find like the local interaction is
actually very
like common in many network systems
so now let's talk about the challenges
so i think in the previous like past few
days we have been seeing like a lot of
talk trying to address the cursive
dimensionality and in there that's the
first challenge we're going to face and
the one difference here is i introduce
an individual state of individual agent
so the cursive dimensionality is not
just about the action also the state
dimension it will quickly blow up as i
have one more number of agents now
there's another challenges actually
mostly come from like when i was
thinking about how i'm going to really
apply whatever policy i learned so
second challenge come from here so let's
suppose this is kind of the global view
right i have this certain kind of
magical learner and learn the good
policy and the policy will specify the
relationship the mapping from the state
i mean that's content situation of the
entire system and to action
so what's really going on now if i think
about individual actuator at one
location right how possible that i can
really have in this global information
so would they say that even i have a
like don't worry about the learning
people tell me this is the best policy
you should go have to take this is
impossible to really take in that action
because it is information limited
information for individual agent so this
motivated us to think about the would
the policy want to learn the policy we
want to learn should be implementable in
some sense and for the talk i'm focusing
on the streaming case like that's what's
the title of the target set localized
policy so let's just learn some local
policies the local policies means for
each agent i would like to know
eventually getting a local policy that i
can take my action based on i observed
locally
and for the extreme case i just had my
own state as i as the police i want to
learn so i want to say like this work
can be extended to adding the local
policy based on the neighboring
information but focus on the simple case
fully low class policy based on the
local state what we get
so they're kind of challenging one
challenge in two now let's look at right
if my goal is only to learn the
localized policy like doesn't mean i can
just do the independent learning so we
have been singing talks in the past days
like talking about independent learning
and how the independent learning going
to evolve so my argument here is like my
goal is i want to optimize the globalism
perspective so even i only learn my
localized policy but because my state
transition still couples everyone
together and that means my local policy
we're still affecting the entire system
so ideally if i really want really care
about the global system performance what
i need to do i need probably still
communicate so that's why the
communication come to play is so what we
want to do during the learning is we
would like to run some learning rules
and it's kind of called that disability
learning rule the learning rule should
use in the like local state every agent
using their local state and putting a
quote on the local because we're going
to define what local reading means like
the local state added through his own
observation uh his local communication
and the local reward he observed to
learn a good local policies
so that's the
like ultimate goal we want to achieve
and everything's still cooperative i'm
not talking about like agent play
according to their best interest i can
see what we can achieve
so now let's dive into like design the
algorithm so when we put into the
algorithm we graph is there's so many i
o different type of method i haven't
focused on the policy gradient in this
talk
so this is like what do the policy
gradient i do familiarization you can
just think about the simplest
conversation you're going to do to do
the like direct conversation for example
and the difficulty is how to revise the
policy gradient if i don't know the
model right a lot of work is like one
popular mastery to using the policy
gradient theorem that's which is able to
just based on the q function which is
expected long-term reward to evaluate or
estimate the policy gradient so one
essential component for the policy
gradient theorem is to evaluate the q
function which for the tabular case we
can call this as a queue table
and what that one is this is a single
agent for information case is if i
really go ahead to implement this method
what i need is
i need a
big joint table that tells me how good
i'm doing based on the current entire
global state and global action profile
as we talk about cursive dimensionality
like hey this table is just
exponentially large depending how many
number of agents that have and the
system we have in our mind is always
really very large scale system and on
the other hand it's actually also needed
global information how can i really have
the global information
in such a good time
so those are the two challenges now
let's like if i put into the setting
because my problem the network mdp do
have some structures so i want to see
that for my structure does that
structure give me some benefit so we put
in the policy gradient by putting our io
the mdp problem into the setting to see
what we have
so we have like learn we only want to
learn the localized policy and the look
at the policy is for each agent c that i
and everyone they take in their own
local policies and the joint policy is
the product of all the local policies
right nothing fancy here just like
writing down what we really want to have
and then writing down the q different q
function definition the q function is
just a summation of the expected reward
and the expected reward is the summation
of every individual nose reward i just
put in them and exchanging the summation
of the order then to kind of naturally
ever have something can call it q i ceda
which is like the long term expiry
reward for one agent qi
so the intuition for this q i c that
looks nice that is for individual agent
that's how good my expected long-term
reward if i start with s a and taking
the policy theta
but the one difficulty here is this
individual queue table is still
exponentially large right if any because
the state transition couple everyone
eventually i need have to know what's
going on with the entire system as an a
the first challenge we look at here like
i cannot really proceed anymore
instead of challenges like now i'm going
to write down my post agreements here so
now for each the policy gradient feature
agent going to take the partial gradient
of his own action policy see that i and
writing down everything and there's one
component
like this is good but then for here
because my q is a summation of
everyone's q again that means i need
everyone's information
so the both the q table and the policy
gradient tells me like i cannot
reproceed if i really have a large score
system
so now what we should do
like let me summarize the challenge we
have here right we had making once more
progress is for individual agent i so
you can imagine you are the agent i in
the network so i know like the way i
should do it to evaluate
like how good the situation is the for
the expected long-term reward and the qi
but that one will depending on the
entire system which i don't have the
information of other agents
so how should i proceed
we i will give you like a few seconds to
think about your own solution
now okay good i guess so probably many
of you will already have some of your
own solution you want to try and the way
like i think we listen to the
independent
learner talk that we can probably just
cheating individual agent i think
independent lender go ahead
i can use some mean field
tools if my system i further added some
assumption about the mean field property
and the thing i want to say is like
something we did it's kind of something
between the independent learner and
entire
centralized learning is i'm not like i
cannot really evaluate my entire qi for
the like
joint state joint action but what i can
do because i can still see what's going
on around me if you think about when
you're driving you actually can always
know what's happening nearby and
especially with the google map
so now i'm going to just like do a
simple thing since to the truncation
depending how much memory i have
depending on how much computation i have
or how much communication i have i'll
just
do it one truncation based on my ability
and the call is like i can't change it
that's kind of the local as i talked
about before the local means i can
define what kind of k-hop neighbor i
want to do depending on my ability so
this is the question that's a truncation
really going to work by just ignore the
existence of other agents
like the
good news is
the truncation just by ignoring others
the existing other agents work to a
certain degree because for the system at
describing
the network mdp problem has oneness
structure like we call the exponential
declining property so what the
exponential indicating property here
says is so yes i need for the long term
reward for individual agent i need to
note in higher
state and entire action profile but if
one agent is really far away from me and
then the effect of that agent stand
action
only play a small effect
and as the distance getting longer the
effect actually will get the exponential
decay and the row is a decaying factor
so one i put in the discounting reward
case as an example to talk about here
because everyone can kind of think about
okay you have a discounting reward so
each time by the time when
one agent
affects another agent is already being
discounted by the distance between the
two agents so kind of one intuition but
i want to highlight is actually the true
decaying factor is much better than the
decaying disclaim factor gamma and
that's one of the reason why we can
extend the result to the
limit averaging case even without
discounting the reward it still has
explanation decaying property for most
networks that we have encountered
so
yes questions
what is what is wrong
like i mean if you're in your
proposition here like okay like you said
smaller
[Music]
right yeah so like um
the question about the what's the role
right yeah
so the the gamma is the discounting
factor i talked about before so like by
the argument that i said before like
definitely so that the heading was
smaller than the kidding
actually was more than the gamma and the
row was a real row here like um
it's as it's a consequence of the net
structure discounting factor and also
the mixing rate of mdp
and we do not have a concrete form for
the row but like through all the
numerical simulation we have been seeing
like for many cases if we just random
generating a network the row can be
substantially smaller than the gamma and
the row what here means just means how
fast the exponent decaying is so smaller
the row is the better
if my row is really small that means i
can basically ignore the existence of
other agents but if my row is very close
to one so here is a smaller one or equal
to one that actually means the
truncation
the quality of a truncation is not going
to be that good
and if my row is very small i can pick
very very small k of neighbor
does this kind of answer your question
but we so far we still don't have the
like analytical form about hey what's
the better like
bond for the law
sounds good yeah thank you i would like
to ask one question
why we avoid to
why we're trying to compute the
gradient
via the saturn's
two function and
we don't try to do reinforce
estimator we do not try to do what can
repeat or not
uh
i still couldn't uh hear clearly can you
right why not force estimator
i mean estimated right so um like i said
like so put it this way first of all
when we start this one we will try into
the active critique framework uh we kind
of using the policy gradient and the
policy gradient i haven't really even
talked about like now this part is only
about the queue function
so so i think i think what the question
was was it was specifically like so
there's different versions of the policy
gradient theorem right so you wrote down
the one that has like the q functions
there's also the one that just involves
like the realized rewards right
so the policy gradient like let's say
that first of all for here it's only
related to the queue so not to do with
that whatever positive way we're going
to do like you won't do any other cubase
method this one probably still is needed
and then back to the question about like
the policy gradient right i can do some
other estimation like for example the
zeros order this kind of way to do it
and then another difficulty is kind of
back to even if you're doing it everyone
that's it i assume
like for the second everyone observe his
own local ri and my global my objective
is i want to maximize the joint reward
so no matter what kind of way we're
going to do we need to figure out a way
to estimate the global reward
and like indeed actually we have another
paper on a different setting like on uh
more like on the continuous state
control action space and for that one we
actually did some other way to estimate
the global reward it's not through the
truncation
yeah but either way it's it's unaware
that we need to figure out a way to
estimate and estimate is not going to be
accurate because the like scale of the
system
does that kind of answer the question
yeah that makes sense
great thank you thumbs up also oh wait i
think there's one one more question let
me mike over here
it's a very small one but can you
explain again what s prime and a prime
is here because i maybe oh yeah okay
okay that's good so sorry so i found
notation wise so here um
like this is means the k-hop neighbor
see that this means scale of neighbor
and then this means like all the agent
that says outside the care of the
neighbor oh so you have the neighbors in
the left one and then the neighbors
outside yeah yeah yeah
these are neighbors there's another
neighbors and what it says like the
people like the prime means
for the people who are not my kelp
neighbor no matter what he did has a
very small effect on me oh okay thanks
yeah and that's one of the reason why we
can do truncation because it doesn't
really have much effect yeah okay i see
thank you okay great thank you for the
questions
okay
now like
look at back to the q function so i say
now we did the truncation and the reason
why the transition worked because
exponential
so like kind of solving kind of one
challenge like for the joint queue table
even though if you don't do the policy
gradient doing some other mastery
probably you can apply this kind of way
and to adding performance guarantee on
the quality of the queue that we would
like to have like a truncated q function
and now back to the gradient right i
said multiple way to do the gradient and
we like for this paper we did this
polarized gradient so the full policy
gradient is when we writing down i just
writing down the
partial gradient and partial gradient
and this is like summation of all the
long term expanded reward so we kind of
figure one issue out is we did the
truncated one and this is okay but then
this has the global summation how are we
going to do that
the there is a technical proof is turns
out if i already start with the small
truncated q actually when we really go
ahead to re write the policy gradient we
should now need to do the summation of
the global summation we just need the
local summation and like whatever
showing in this truncated q table then
keep that one as the neighbors
so that's actually another benefit like
by at least for this part if i go ahead
to my q and then so like it happens then
my
policy gradient i don't need to do the
global summation i only need the local
summation
putting all things together so it's
ultimately what we did is we putting on
one good way to estimate the global
policy gradient and we can
ensure the quality of the gradient
estimation and how good the
estimation will depending on the
decaying factor and like also how many
neighbors i will pick like hey hope
neighbor
if it didn't go good one we probably
should pick a larger one
so
any questions so now you can see like if
i have this tool yes i would like to ask
one question
do you have even some heuristic that you
can describe about some specific
structures of networks that can describe
that all
like
if i have a cycle you can tell me that
raw is something like two or one and
you have even heuristically just to
get some idea about the different
networks that someone can see
uh
good question uh we got that question
for like every time when we talk about
this work so um bring this way let me
talk about the k hawk neighbor so first
of all the result is general like you
can be a line network can be
like uh like fully connected that means
you actually including everyone's
information can be any other kind of
network you can have a cycle in the
system that's also okay and uh k-hope
neighbor so far what we
have of defined it really means if i
if two agents like from the link and you
can look at my link right now is you
through the definition like you put in
the hub of neighbor as long as if any
agent that is belonging to the kelp
neighbor then that one should be
included
so in the extreme case right so people
have the complete kinetic graph that
that means every agent will be included
so like if i really want to say this one
can bring down the
uh complexity this means i kind of
already online assuming the graph should
relatively sparse
otherwise i don't have much benefit
because the github neighbor probably for
some agent if there's a one agent kind
of connecting with everyone put that
agent here actually including everyone's
information
so from theoretical computer science
perspective if i give you an expander
for example can you somehow estimate
how much is
yeah uh so
what the opposite expander
right right so yeah yeah yeah
yeah and once i want to highlight is
this um because we didn't making further
assumption of what kind of pi like the
local say transition we're going to do
the
the row factor here well depending on
the network structure but also highly
depending on the pi
the say transition probability
yeah that's why it's becoming
complicated to like just putting a nice
thing to say hey if i have this graph
what will happen this graph that
happened but what uh something we didn't
try is probably if i kind of start with
hey about the pi if you have like um k
agent it has a k degree and then
automatically your pi will be like upper
bounded by one over k we didn't do those
things and that's why we don't have the
conversation of the row but if we're
making further assumption what kind of
pi well and how the pi is getting up
with the network that probably some
result can help
it's good so i will go to next size it's
already 13 minutes sorry so
but thank you for the questions
now
now like you can see what that what we
can do is just like putting all this in
together right you can learn the
truncated q function using the local
information and do the truncated policy
gradient as we already discussed i said
like the experiment detailing is not
really tightly
tied with the policy gradient so if i do
the q learning method i can use in this
similar message with q learning but
figure out the way how to upgrade the
queue
um we like but we didn't try those
methods but it's something we want to
try i think inspired by the titles of
relearning by choosing for something we
can do is do some like the we learning
type of thing that i can totally just
get rid of the dependence on the a but
uh that's just some idea recently why
listen to the talks through the workshop
now now about the performance guarantees
i still won't still want to spending
five minutes to talk about something i
found that's very interesting and a
connection with all the games so now the
problems guarantee we have like it's
kind of
quite standard i think like this is the
one this is the episode so from the
learning that if we do the active
critique method have the two time scale
so this is kind of episode m so this is
the episode so it's one over
scroll of m i think i'm consistent with
the learning result for the centralized
case and then this is the arrow because
i did a truncation so that no matter
what i cannot really making this one be
like
to zero so it's always a arrow in uh
introduced by the truncation and one
nice thing i didn't show those
polynomials but just kind of you guys
should believe me so all these
polynomials well just depending on the
size like the state actions based out of
the k-haw neighbors so it's like there's
no term the size of the network n is not
going to show up in those foreign owners
and that's kind of the goal of we want
to do from the beginning so we won't
have some algorithm that's kind of can
like scalable to
the large size of the network and this
is a theoretical guarantee we had a
simulation and given the intro times i'm
not going to talk about too much but i
want to highlight so the connection of
what we did
with the independent learners as we
because we listened to some talks on the
independent learner it's like by making
the k up neighbor to be zero like don't
using any other neighbor's information
just as your own local state reward like
to run to see what's going on and we
actually simulate those uh algorithm
indeed by doing that will be actually
better than like this is some benchmark
algorithm so if i have time i'm happy to
tell you a little more what we did for
this uh
for this example but as i mentioned
earlier i said we actually had some
other setting because this setting was
okay to model something really to the
like networking or wireless
communication which like we can say the
state action probably is kind of finite
or you have like one two three you can
count countable and we we had some other
like collaboration like we was asking us
about the
continuous space
and we can also not re making the
assumptions say the reward is bounded if
you think about lqr case right the cost
function is never going to be bounded if
i don't have any other assumptions so we
actually had other settings and for
other settings i'm not going to talk
about details is we indeed like we have
a different way to estimate the gradient
not the way i was showing to you before
and there's a one challenges i want to
highlight for when i was working on this
problem it's actually the stability
guarantee if i don't really assuming
boundless and then i
is what happens my state while going to
the dangerous
uh like um the unsafe region so we had a
like through the way design
like the way of estimation of the
gradient to kind of overall to ensure
the stability of the learning so if
you're interested uh we'll refer you to
this talk but now
i while spending a few minutes to talk
about something i think for me i find
that it's very interesting that i kind
of finally uh claimed myself that wasn't
exactly going on so i talked about like
oh multiple goal is for the cooperative
setting maximize the global reward but
you can see right the result is only in
the stationary guarantee so we asked the
question i was exactly this point ah
so we started that question and so then
in the meantime then we find algobus
paper on the single agent type mdp case
like for example for derived policy
gradient the stationary point is
actually equivalent to the opening point
which is a very prominent thing i like
encouraging when we read this paper and
also because the online
property for the single agent has a
great domination so for our case we only
have one agent i think our algorithm
just becoming a policy gradient like
this paper so then we want to see like
that's what happened for our case that
we had uh
two things and we run some other like so
this actually the other simulations
indeed depending on the initial point we
will have a different value so that
means the definitely not really global
optimal and there can be so many points
so and then we look at like what's
exactly going on what did what exactly
we do for our problem so this is the
like back to this picture that would
just say two things uh two differences
compared with centralized learning so
one is like even when you have a single
agent i think what we kind of forcing
ourselves to do is like the partial
observable system like every agent just
taking the action based on his partial
observation and we know like the paul
mdp is challenging that's probably what
making the opposition landscaping
harder and then another thing is here i
kind of
assume every agent taking their action
independently right it's kind of like
the decentralized policy the independent
agent so these two kind of fundamental
differences compared with a single agent
so then we look into like we kind of
separate the two challenges to really
working like understanding whatever we i
talked about before is super challenging
we don't know what the starting point so
we kind of break the two challenges
first do some problem dp now point mdp
like the partial bezier lqr study what
we can have and then we also look at the
table mdp for the independent learner
what we can have
so like as i said i really want to share
this one is probably is obvious for many
of audience uh here so i will try to
finish in four minutes by telling you
the some things i found that's
interesting so now actually i went to
the extreme case i said i i didn't do
game theory at all i just it's fully
cooperative setting so now i can go
ahead and make my apartment relatively
easier compared with the problem i
talked about before so now okay let's
forget the states local state i will i
can allow them to share the state but
action still going to be the local
action and say transition this is a
transition and because now i only kind
of think about the one joint state
everyone can observe and also for here
right since i talk about cooperative
setting just global objective i just put
in the global objective to everyone's
reward that's kind of the like
multi-agent mdp setting that's what i
did before is everyone want to solve the
global
one i even assume they have the global
reward i want to maximize and now i only
keep this
feature the feature is decent policy and
now the policy everyone going to take is
the joint policy
so
like i think this is very similar to the
talk we listen like this morning and
also in the past two days we had the
stochastic games right the only
difference is now i'm just doing
identical interest putting to be more
like cooperative setting so we can do
different primarization we can do a soft
maximization let me focus on this one to
talk about something interesting i found
this like i recently think is
interesting so now the question as i
mentioned i just not under this simple
setting but not really not very
complicated there's no conflict
and draw on the policy gradient and i
didn't talk about how to do the sample
based gradient let's say you have the
gradient right what's going on
so the policy gradient
at the best right would be going
guaranteed is going to reach to our
first order stationary point so this
kind of equivalent point from this
learning dynamics
and now like what's it got this
searching point so definitely we know
it's not optimal i already showed that
we drawn the different simulation it
would have different points
and one good news is that's kind of
connecting back you want to start with a
cooperative setting
now it's actually
the equivalence is the stationary point
is equivalent to the nash equilibrium
because the information constraint like
i didn't allow them to
coordinate when they take into action
even though
they share the same global
like share the same
reward function
and so we look at this one first i would
say we think we had a nice result
because now i know what different point
i got right it's going to be nice
equivalent which is i feel oh now i know
what's the point but then the now that i
after sticking the stuff right then this
actually tells me
this method actually not really working
very well because even for the simplest
setting that's what we end up and we
know from all the talks right the next
equilibrium is non-unique even for that
end of interest case and the quality of
natural can be very poor and what's
really happening if i just run this
algorithm i kind of change my
cooperative setting to become an
uncooperative
i don't have an answer to to like solve
this that's why i say it's interesting
because putting me into thinking what we
can do so like in just like one last
minute i want to just say is
the result from here the equivalence is
not really unique to the identical
interest so this morning we had the top
formulas talking about markup potential
game
which had another structure about
potential function
question in the identical interest
setting do you have a convergence rate
for this
uh yes we have uh
okay
we have yes and no but we have a
conversation for the first order
searching point okay yes uh that's
equivalent but but we don't have these
questions we don't have the quality of
the natural program this one yeah but we
have a 2021 paper
yeah yeah yeah it's a different paper so
i will in two slides you will see it and
almost
we agree that in principle it is like
non-convex
distributed
optimization
if we have a if we apply just gradient
play in that identical interest case and
i have
a
an exact estimation of the grade here
then what i imply more or less is
non-complex distributed
optimization
right
yeah yeah yeah uh you you have a very
good point so and the thing that's why
for here when i say it's kind of on
certain degree is that your good news
because like if you draw a general
non-converse problem and natural
equivalent equivalent to the first order
situation condition this one will be
okay but then the other round is
actually harder if you don't have any
structure of the fee so the reason why
it's actually equivalent is because my
fee is actually coming from my it's my
long-term reward for my mdp problem
and so uh this morning is talking about
why is from the mpg i will have a like
two side to show you like it's this is
not a random uh like uh just like one
common like
ordinary non-converter position this is
a fee it's coming from the
reward function from the mdp it has a
structure once i do in the direct
conversation yeah
but you you're like just two slides so
what i want to put in here the
equivalence is since i don't i don't
have any progress about cooperative
setting then actually i go how can how
about just like non-corporate setting
from beginning so every agent have a
different reward and everything every
agent just want to maximize their own
reward right and in that setting that
kind of like the success again that they
propose originally very sharply and kind
of consistent with the rest of the talk
other people's talk talking about
success again
so
the first order stationary
condition is actually equivalent to the
nash equilibrium even for the general
setting so basically the style i showed
you before that's what has not to do
with identical interest right you don't
have a cooperative it's just becoming
uncooperative and like i want to
highlight this actually for general i
don't need any other structure as long
as it's a tabular stochastic again so i
have this chloride
so it looks good and the reason so now
bacteria and why i say it's not ordinary
like noun quantization is the green
domination property so i not i don't
have time to go to the details this
morning jan is from the mpg describing
what the green domination i want to
highlight is screen nomination for this
property is not just like it's a host
for the general success again i don't
really need a potential structure so
this one holds in general
so but then where i really need some
structure like the identical interest so
now back to the question like do we have
a convergence rate for those
problems
yes and no no means if i don't have any
structure for the ji i don't have like
we listened to the task we have a noaa
talking about complexity of the
equivalence and you know like this is
not really learnable if i have algorithm
have commerce 3 then it's great no so
for the general game i don't have so the
no global convergence rate for the
general success again they can be
cycling because those kind of ji
right it's not going to be consistent
like for the zero sum you have some
structure for the general sum like hard
to know but
just uh like one slide to summarizing
some results from two papers so what we
can do is this so for the general case
what we have is we can study some
local geometry of the nash equilibrium
and this is kind of like um i think from
the non-linear dynamics point of view
right i have a dynamics system so i
can't go how to study i know the nash
equivalent is kind of one of those
sequence points and i can go ahead and
study the stability and we have some
result characterizing some nash
equilibrium for the local geometry now
back to the identical interest so the
identical interest like is
they they didn't play a role in showing
the equivalence between the stitching
point and print one but they do play a
role to help me to study the convergence
because now my j is just one j i can use
in the gradient accent method to study
the convergence and we can have a
compressed rate i want to highlight
right it's just say converted to one
natural
which one is highly depending on the
initial one
so and then we can go ahead developing
sample based method so yeah
young is for their paper it had a model
free method and we had a sound like
model based message so far our commerce
rate had been consistent
and
i know like some there's some other
extension improvement on this line of
work and we also look into like the soft
max policies because for the work i
talked about first we actually did the
softmax conversation for that localized
policy so we look into what is happening
for the softmax policies the message is
more complicated i'm not going to talk
about here is uh in our recent paper it
should be 2002 22 not
so now i want to say yes please
the local convergence is about the exact
gradient
yes yes yes
um
sorry
yes the local memory is about the exact
gradient well we didn't really do the
sample based method and one thing i want
to add is
like um
streak mesh phase and felice result is
because it's kind of quite stable once
it's quite stable it means this has
stability margin uh like has uh the like
some like my background from robots
control so like i mean i didn't i always
actually like the absolute arrow here
even no matter what the sample base or
some other way so it's actually for some
result if you add in some perturbation
i'm not talking about base uh they can
still hold to some degree
yeah i have a clarification question
um so in the previous slide you had this
grading dominance property which made it
seem like any stationary point is a nash
global nash
so now you're saying you can't convert
like i don't understand the left-hand
side of this slide
given the grading domination theorem
so uh
good question okay we got those kind of
questions from the reward as well so why
put into the green domination you look
at here this is i'm putting a quote on
the green domination it is it's not as
nice as the green domination like the
single agent right you have the optimal
you have a global unique of nemo point
and you can find the difference between
the
uh j theta with the j c that star and
look at this one this is the kind of
fake green nomination is for every kind
of j the c
i minus i
and then like this is everything and
then this you can pick one being the
best action and to come here so this one
and also those kind of measures will
change according to where i am so the
proof when we have a kind of a
nash equilibrium gap
and the natural gap it defines that
there's no point being fixed at some
anywhere
so that's kind of one of the difficulty
and then this is actually the same this
is actually from the normal form again
right and the reason because if i
overall i want the like the
back to one highlight this one another
thing i want to highlight here is a ji
right for each agent j i i have some
this kind of property but i don't have
anything saying like globally
like because every city i they're going
to change but what happened for the
global system i don't have that that
one's the reason like this kind of is
the that's kind of great nomination it's
not really ruling out this kind of
cycling argument and that kind of also
one of the reason why i say for this
part right why this one why those going
to work because now i don't talking like
i really have a little bit more real
grade nomination i have the kind of same
j
to talk about how the
the gap between the j c da and the j
star
so then could you consider global
um nash if you
had taken your reparameterization to be
shared like the parameter to be shared
with by all players
um
so i don't i don't have answers for this
question yet because i think like how to
properize the policy like amongst your i
i can't even yes i would because listen
to the talks i think people come
noah and trijin right you guys have a
different way to say the policy pie and
extend to the cce the things and i i
don't know so for for my setting i guess
the reason why i'm asking is because i
didn't totally
i understand um because you see it still
seems like you have the first order
equivalence with nash
i didn't totally understand a point with
the grading domination thing but we i
think it had to deal with just one
player's things do not match each
other's first yeah yeah right so because
here the this square nomination adding a
quote here is for every agent you have
the j i minus j i but then everyone's ji
they can be not not aligned at all
okay okay that makes cool perfect thank
you so much okay that's why if i talking
by equivalent that's that's enough
because the equivalence is really
fascinating this one equals zero okay
awesome yeah that means yeah i think we
should wrap up
yeah okay good so i already wrap up this
is my final size so what i want to say
when i want to say this is the most
important one i see i start i really
want to solve this kind of societal
system and then i have an information
communication constraint forced me to do
the localized design policy and then
kind of naturally like emerges from my
algorithm kind of policy gradient
station plan we want to study and then
happily becoming natural program and
then becoming kind of non-cooperative
setting and then lead us to think about
those questions is we know like for the
normal form games the log star is
talking about poa possible energy price
of stability uh if this one a bad if i
have really bad nash equilibrium because
i cannot guarantee which nitrogram is
converted to and can i redesign my
tuning function like adding tax uh
regular i think from our io society you
can get support like using the localizer
language right kind of using a regulator
to kind of shape what's the quality of
nash equilibrium and what kind of not to
communicate right here i just want to
shape what the prime converted to in a
more general setting i put it in this
way right there many other learning
methods and they are for the
colorization of the learning dynamics
this is like one way it turns out to be
the natural equipment what about other
things and eventually can we really come
back to do some real applications for
the cytodynamical system that would be
very exciting so thank you everyone
thank you for all the questions
but
yeah in the interest of time maybe if
people have more questions they can ask
lena offline so why don't we just have
like a quick like two or three minute
break to give doris time to get set up
and then we'll go on to the next talk
great thank you i will stay here also
thanks again thank you